[Music]
china the middle kingdom
an economic world power that presents
itself not only through its far-reaching
culture but also through its
forward-looking technology
in many areas of industry china is one
of the leading countries but the country
does not seem to be open to all new
technologies
the crypto industry with its miners seem
to be a thorn in the economic power side
china has banned all crypto transactions
and also announced that it will stop the
mining of digital assets the most severe
blow to the industry so far
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
the people's republic of china is not
enthusiastic when it comes to the
cryptocurrency stars and especially the
number one bitcoin has had a long
intense dispute with china since its
invention
trading the world's oldest
cryptocurrency is not welcome in the
people's republic of china after all it
was china that helped bitcoin achieve
its current fame
finally it is thanks to the numerous
pioneers and miners from china that
countries like salvador or venezuela
offer bitcoin as an alternative means of
payment
nevertheless the chinese government's
negative attitude towards cryptocurrency
has become increasingly clear and
incisive over time
but the chinese authorities are going
even further in their efforts to
suppress crypto trading
crypto transactions are considered
illegal financial activities including
services offered by offshore exchanges
the people's bank of china reported on
its website
it added that cryptocurrencies including
bitcoin and tether are not a real fiat
currency and thus cannot be in
circulation
bitcoin crashed after the announcement
falling 8
to around 43 000
broad money laundering and excessive
energy use are all associated with
cryptocurrencies
the enormous energy consumption of
crypto mining is also a reason why the
entire crypto industry is under scrutiny
the chinese economic planning authority
explained that it was their job to take
tough action and stop crypto mining in
order not to jeopardize the government's
set climate targets
china is facing a severe energy crisis
that has already affected commodities
such as aluminum and steel
the country hosts about 50 of the
world's crypto miners and had a 46 share
of the global highest rate a measure of
the computing power used in mining and
processing
will bitcoin and the crypto industry
succeed without china
what do the analysis and crypto industry
experts have to say about the latest
development in china
let's get back to china's increasing
crackdown on crypto it looks like
they've gone absolute at this point
saying on the pboc website they will ban
all transactions or that all crypto
transactions are illegal we do see um
bitcoin's price falling down below 44 uh
thousand down below forty three thousand
right now forty two nine hundred twelve
let's get to joanna ostinger our asia
crypto czar for more on what this
actually means um joanna it seems like
from now on everything that you want to
do besides simply holding
crypto if you already have it is illegal
is that the am i reading this correctly
hi matt that's kind of what it looks
like but the question always with these
things from china is what does it mean
in practice you know we've had the
crackdowns before over the years and
people have been able to do workarounds
and able to they keep exchanges going
even though they they crack down on
exchanges there are a lot of people who
still hold crypto um so you'll see even
for bitcoin and the crypto complex
generally the drop that we've seen is
actually not that big so it tells you
that it's not that much of a surprise
but it's definitely not being you know
it it's definitely not increasing the
prices either right
so jenna why are they doing this now
they've been wanting to do it do they
feel emboldened by everything else is it
a distraction because of what's going on
with evergrand
it might be that they're they're seeing
you know the sec in the us is cracking
down on things as well they are seeing
other regulators taking steps but you
know china does things when it does them
right so it's a little bit hard to tell
exactly it could be that they're
concerned about something with evergreen
but it could just be that they're
looking at crypto overall and saying
this is the time when we want to take
this step because they've been going at
it you know since before evergrand was
really getting people's attention
yeah is there concern by the way
that
retail investors are going to get burned
speculating in this
asset or is there concern that wealthy
chinese people are going to use it to
move
wealth offshore
there's probably some of both in there
and again yeah i i don't have firsthand
knowledge of this but it there is um
speculation that it's it's both of these
things and actually one thing to watch
with this would be tether which is seen
as key in terms of flows into crypto
from china and recently i was looking at
prices it's about 99.1
and it's usually a dollar so that will
be interesting with insight and analysis
let's get straight to eddie van der
waals our great crypto watcher bloomberg
m live strategist so eddie good morning
first of all we're trying to figure out
exactly how for how much further this
goes right they china had already
declared a war on bitcoin absolutely and
and this seems to be a step further in
trying to ban it completely look it does
feel like an escalation doesn't it if
they are really saying no transactions i
would like to know exactly what that
means does that mean i cannot buy with
it or does it mean that i can't transact
with you i cannot send you bitcoin from
my phone to your phone
you know so so that i can no longer
trade it on an exchange so i i'm still a
little bit vague on what it means uh
what a transaction is in this particular
circumstances and how strictly they'll
enforce enforce it but it is
confirmation china doesn't like this and
bitcoin at the moment still needs china
and chinese investors you know there's a
lot of chinese investors that have been
long bitcoin and have been using it and
have been building it up so it's an
escalation and and we shall see how much
you know crypto prices respond to it
yeah i think it's interesting
um francine makes a good point that
they've
incrementally been fighting again they
banned exchanges they banned mining but
it looks like what they're saying is
and the emphasis is on the word all
all crypto related transactions are
illegal
to me that means any time you want to
trade it be it for goods and services or
trading with friends
any kind of crypto related transactions
are illegal and i mean just looking at
the price it doesn't seem to have hit
bitcoin
that hard right now we're looking at a
drop of three percent of still 43 351
how important is the chinese market to
bitcoin
the chinese market is extremely
important and you know the question is
how how well china will be able to
enforce this i do wonder though uh matt
whether this is
whether we are talking about a ban of
transactions or a ban of ownership
because if we if ownership is still
legal then effectively you will have to
be able to trade it somehow but if it's
about transactions and i won't be able
to pay for goods and services with it
then it's an escalation but not as
serious as it as it had been right
because then it is no longer a financial
instrument either which it
for the most part let's face it bitcoin
is not used that much for transacting in
the financial system it is used as a
financial asset as well well although it
puts it
it puts it really in a gray area this is
like in the us
this was the issue with marijuana a lot
in a lot of states you could
own it you could hold it but you weren't
allowed to buy it or sell it so the
question was how do i get it well um the
law didn't make that clear they just
said you cannot buy it or sell it but
you can hold it and that may be the same
uh case with bitcoin here
well it's clear it's clear which way the
direction of travel is here in china
right i think that for me is the message
i we know that china is not keen on
cryptocurrencies in general particularly
ones that they don't control so you know
uh central bank digital asset will be a
completely different thing but but but
but for the for the for the wide
spectrum of cryptocurrencies i don't
think that they have made it clear that
this is not something that they like
eddie the crackdown in china is not
unfortunately limited to
cryptocurrencies they've been cracking
down really as our tom mckenzie put it
to us on risk across the board and that
includes in the property sector which
raises the evergreen question
we have no idea what happened with the
dollar coupon bond payment yesterday
whether or not they actually met that
deadline what happens in the next 24-48
hours
from from china and in general i i think
we we we have to wait and see we have to
wait and see whether there is any
contagion that comes from this and yes i
think you know the chinese system it it
it's it's uncomfortable bedfellows with
uh with with capitalism in general and
therefore you know it's it's a
it's a hard case for them to make um in
general that you know trading and and
free markets and letting people
speculate as much as they want so so
some sort of crackdown is possible but
but for the evergrand fallout i think it
is possible that you know that china
contains this it is not an it's not
something that they can prove that they
cannot prevent the spillovers if they
wanted to so you know with a particular
bondholders will lose money that isn't
but one question but they can stop the
financial system from seizing up
china is well aware of the potential of
blockchain technology and has even
introduced its own digital currency the
digital run
also the chinese company tencent had
already launched a program called q coin
in 2007
which was used in its own messaging
service qq and also opened its own
secondary market
as a result in 2009 the chinese
government banned the use of digital
currencies for the purchase of real
goods and services bitcoin was one of
them but was not explicitly mentioned in
the ban
however the fact that the chinese
population already has experience with
digital currencies worked in their favor
china has therefore became the center of
the young crypto industry over the years
meanwhile the chinese government decided
to wait for the development of digital
coin which in turn opened up
opportunities for crypto companies to
explore in new ways
the first chinese bitcoin exchange btc
china was founded in 2011 followed by
the crypto platforms huawei and bitmain
in 2013 with companies such as baidu
immediately accepting bitcoin payments
this in turn attracted the attention of
china's currency regulators
in december 2013 they announced that
chinese financial institutions would no
longer be allowed to process bitcoin
transactions they declared bitcoin an
illegal means of payment
this announcement came at a time when
bitcoin trading had already taken off
considerably and the bitcoin price
exceeded the 1 000 mark for the first
time almost 10 days before the ban
after the announcement bitcoin's value
on the world's largest bitcoin exchange
at the time crashed by over 30
for crypto industry insiders china's
crypto ban did not come as a complete
surprise
bitcoin mining however was excluded from
the ban this was still allowed and
favorable conditions quickly made china
and el dorado or bitcoin mining
companies
although the regulator did not prevent
individuals from trading bitcoin they
advised those involved to be aware of
the associated risks
[Music]
we know that china has been taking steps
in this direction but this is incredibly
dramatic i mean
what is your take on this what does this
mean for even a company like falcon x
sure so you know i think china has been
banning cryptocurrency for a number of
years now first in 2013 2017 this is not
the first time they've done so this year
and for an authoritarian regime that's
trying to promote their digital one and
keeping in mind that the china national
holiday is next week their crackdown on
crypto is what i would really align with
senator pat toomey a big opportunity for
the united states and a reminder of our
structural advantage over china in terms
of you know just what we've seen
historically to what ed mentioned this
definitely wasn't as large of a move as
we've seen uh you know prior times in
market movements we see a red candle
stick down um in panic initially uh
followed by quick buyback and market
recovery for btc largely buy side
led by asia-based hedge funds and for
u.s
institutions across a number of personas
and for eth we're seeing a much larger
hit with a much slower buyback uh driven
by proprietary funds
who are the winners and losers here and
and if you could get into some coins
specifically you know that would
certainly help us better understand the
situation
yeah that's a really really good
question you know i think uh what we
were seeing it was
you know a slower last two months
historically uh for us on the volume
side we saw seven times more volume
today um than we had seen across you
know a number of weeks where we had a
lot of conferences both in traditional
finance and cryptocurrency uh layer ones
are definitely top of mind i know uh you
have spoken um you know about uh layer
ones historically in the past you know
ethereum but also uh things like
avalanche solana uh adam as well as luna
um in addition to bitcoin uh and then
some tokens outside of that uh primarily
looking at uh renewed interest and some
of the play to earn tokens like a ygg or
an axia infinity
and you know china is saying they're
going to investigate anyone working for
overseas cryptocurrency exchanges as
well would any falcon x employees fall
under that umbrella i mean what does
this mean for your employees and the way
that you operate as a company
yeah so falcon x today we do have
offices uh in the us as well as our asia
office
in india so not a direct impact to our
business but i think that's definitely
top of mind for for any business uh that
may have um any employees sitting in in
china as you mentioned
now if you know obviously this is
happening in asia which which used to be
sort of the center of crypto innovation
we're preparing for tougher regulation
here in the united states we're
preparing for tougher regulation on
crypto in europe if that's the case and
you see a broad-based crackdown then
where do you think the growth is going
to come from
yeah that's a really good question i
think you know if we use just china
mining as an example of this uh we saw
china ban mining and we actually saw a
number of those miners come to the
united states so hash rate is almost 70
percent of what it was prior to the ban
so we've almost has a full comeback from
that and a lot of the miners today are
in the us and so uh we really saw that
innovation come to the united states and
again going back to that really an
opportunity for the us to show that
we're at the forefront of working
with this industry
to spark innovation
i think across the board everyone's
trying to protect consumers that is top
of mind for any company in this space
how do we do so without stifling
innovation in 2015 chinese bitcoin
mining companies made up half of the
bitcoin hash rate
the first additional cryptocurrencies to
be exchanged through so-called initial
coin offerings ico were those of the
digital currency
[Music]
in autumn 2017 chinese icos has raised
over 400 million dollars alerting the
chinese government
in an attempt to support the weakening
grin and prevent the illegal outflow of
money from china the country's central
bank began investigating the activities
of crypto exchanges in january 2017.
as a result the investigation focused on
the stock exchange's approach to foreign
exchange management and anti-money
laundering
[Music]
the pboc considered icos to be an
illegal fundraising mechanism event ico
platforms from issuing ico tokens and
ordered that the funds raised through
icos should be returned to investors
among other things the regulator found
that icos threatened the stability of
the country's economy and pose a risk of
business failure the order also
stipulated that financial institutions
and non-bank payment companies may not
offer services that support token-based
fundraising activities
while china's crypto community was still
processing this new reality regulators
issued another directive
only two weeks later crypto exchanges
that allowed the exchange of fiat to
cryptocurrency were definitively banned
as a result many bitcoin platforms moved
their activities abroad while others
were forced to close their platforms
completely
what did you think when you heard about
china's move
i think you know we've seen the
resiliency of the crypto markets uh to
sort of changing regulation uh and
specifically changing regulation in
china several times before uh it's very
hard to eventually predict you know how
any change impacts the the gatekeepers
or the various players in the market but
it's very clear that it's impossible to
regulate bitcoin itself as the protocol
and people's usage of sort of the
decentralized protocol whether it's
bitcoin or others i think in general
there's a lot of discussion about the
fact that you know in september
2017 there was also sort of a big china
ban on crypto on exchanges and after
that we saw sort of the first big crypto
rally of 2017 of bitcoin reaching back
then the records of uh 2017.
i think you know sometimes when you
think about regulating bitcoin it's like
you know a
multiple-headed monster you try to cut
this head and then you get five
additional heads so it's very
interesting to see that resiliency of
the protocol itself yeah you definitely
just called bitcoin hydra but that's
cool we'll just go with that um but to
your point
that's going to be the bull's point that
there's going to be lots of different
avenues and lots of different people who
want to wind up trading bitcoin
if china really cracks down and says you
can't own it which they didn't say but
say they say you can't own it you can't
use it at all and you can't trade it
how does that not have a material impact
on the price and the volume that it can
trade with
you know like i think the global economy
as a global economy is much bigger than
any single state we're seeing a
transition globally by the way in
capital markets as well from capital
markets being a hyper local
where people only trade locally to
capital markets being global and then
obviously crypto markets are hyper
global the opposite
of local capital markets
there's definitely you know there's
always going to be impact of various
regulations in the crypto market but i
think we'll also see
again the resilience of a global
monetary decentralized system and
there's going to be a shift that we
started seeing you know an exciting
shift this year more towards defy to
disregard finance to various protocols i
think this will shift the industry more
towards define
of course the the potential bigger risk
for cryptocurrencies uh and i think
we may agree that uh other
cryptocurrencies are the bigger threat
to uh to central banks uh rather than
bitcoin which is kind of in a class of
its own for better or worse but the risk
is the other central banks notably the
federal reserve uh and certainly the ecb
weighing in and actually deciding how
and when and what form these things can
trade and whether the central banks want
their own fiat-based digital currency
which could happen how big a risk is
that and is that some of what we're
seeing priced in here
so you know as always i'm an optimist so
any risk is an opportunity
there's no doubt we're seeing you know
the the genies out of the bottle we're
seeing the
digitization of money we're seeing
digital transformation happening to
money which is the biggest digital
transformation of everything and i think
the blockchain technology represents
that shift bitcoin represents a new type
of global commodity
and regulators
will look for ways to regulate and
governments to innovate i think we'll
see a lot of central banks and
governments launching their own digital
currencies i think this will run in
parallel to what we call today the
crypto markets are the difference it's a
different type of an asset
but i think you know this process of
moving the entire monetary system into
the digital realm is definitely
something sort of an arms race between a
lot of different countries around the
world yoni last question here quickly um
since china made that announcement what
kind of trading have you seen on your
platform
well we generally see a trading pattern
sort of really reflect with volatility
so as volatility is higher we see more
trading activity uh and as price goes up
so you know we've seen in may that
correction that lowered prices of
bitcoin from all-time high after the
mining ban then we've seen an awakening
on a lot of the d5 protocols in the
beginning of august which sort of
revived a lot of uh new protocols as
well as bitcoin price and eath reaching
almost 4 000 again
and i think now with that correction
we're seeing markets that are a bit
softer than they were a month ago as a
result of such developments some
china-based exchanges relocated their
operations to other countries while
others had to close their businesses in
april 2019 china's national development
and reform commission ndrc identified
bitcoin mining as an undesirable
industry in its preliminary list of
sectors that should be promoted
restricted or eliminated by local
governments bitcoin mining a
computer-intensive process of validating
bitcoin transactions in order to receive
newly coined bitcoin as a reward built
into the catalog of industry that the
agency deemed particularly harmful to
the environment as might be expected
this move caused some panic given that a
significant percentage of bitcoin mining
rigs were made in china moreover more
than half of the world's bitcoin mining
power was located in china as operators
there had access to cheap electricity
although the ndrc eventually dropped
bitcoin mining from his final draft
after much deliberation the whole
episode was an initial step of what was
to come talk us through some of these
these latest lines coming out from china
how is this different why do you think
the market was quick to shrug it off
yeah good morning yvonne so good to be
back the
the latest ban is just an extension of
further tightening of the crypto
policies in china uh this has been
rumored since the summer time that china
will eventually get cut off in terms of
the crypto exchanges market as people
may know four years ago the pboc and the
regulators banned domestic exchanges in
china
and then what happened was many of the
exchanges just moved offshore but yet
we're still servicing people within
mainland china
by requiring them to go through vpn
access and so on so this ban when you
talk about crypto transactions i think
there's a slight mistranslation it's
really emphasized about crypto buying
and selling the crypto purchasing the
crypto exchange transactions that happen
on the exchange platforms so i believe
that private exchanges private buy sells
are still allowed it's just that the
enterprise-led exchanges that action is
now deemed
you know illegal and they were
prosecuted so this is why the recently
in the recent last two days the major
exchange platforms around china have all
announced the stopping of registration
of of chinese users
why do you think china continues to
double down on this bobby is it still
concerns about money laundering and what
you know crypto can actually the risk
that it could bring
or is it more broad now is it about
energy consumption or even the threat of
a digital a threat to the digital remnb
what do you think is motivating beijing
yeah i think it has to do with the
controlled currency as you know you know
in a
in a controlled regime with uh
with forex uh you know
controlled
foreign currencies they really don't
want any loopholes where people can use
a digital currency vehicle to move
assets abroad
so i think that's the main reason is
just to retain the control over the
economy the control of the finances
uh and the outflow of money the
influence outflow of money but in the
end it's not it's not about energy i
think they banned
the mining of crypto earlier this year
for the purpose of alignment with all of
the crypto the timing ban but as i've
said before this is actually not the
final nail in the coffin which would be
the so-called making crypto assets
illegal to hold as well so that clearly
has not happened yet
we've reported for for weeks and months
now about miners in china that are just
packing up their bags
and going
are you able to track me your year on
the ground in shanghai how much activity
has actually shifted out of the country
now
so much of the traditional what they
call proof of power uh cryptocurrency
mining that has moved abroad so this
would be like the bitcoin the litecoin
and the ethereum uh there's a new
category of mining where it involves
proof of stake where it involves like
storage uh the likes of foul coin and
other derivatives
uh those are still happening in china
because it's much harder to detect these
are machines that are regular computers
with uh storage you know solid state
drives and so on and a lot of that
activity is still happening in china but
it's hard to really classify that as
traditional proof of power proof of work
uh mining
so bobby
just talk us through in terms of what
your outlook is right now you talked
about you know
similar crackdowns we've seen from from
beijing has led to a boom
when it comes to bitcoin prices is this
time very much the same you think
yeah it's it's kind of like you know
when the rumor when the rumor is uh so
what is it sell on rumor bionews that's
kind of what's happening right now the
rumor has been in the works for several
months now that china will have a very
tight crackdown on bitcoin this year and
the you know the hammer finally dropped
uh the timing is is reminiscent of what
happened in 2017
when the crackdown came in september in
early september and then of course we
knew that the bitcoin prices rallied
to a multi-year high
at the end of 2017
and this year no different that
with a crackdown now announced sort of
the bad news and that out of the way
uh the market is reacting and processing
digesting that information i think
i i'm very bullish on bitcoin especially
for end of year rally a formal rally
this year so i expect bitcoin prices to
break out again uh in the next few weeks
and months
all right we're still hopping around
that 43 000 level we tumbled below
at that kind of level there over the
weekend it was only five percent
yeah i'm just wondering what what you
know we're still far from that all-time
high around 60 63 000. i mean where do
you think prices are really going to go
if you're talking about year-end rallies
now
so i uh
i think you'll easily go over 100 000
and then depending on how sharp the
rally is it's also likely to even touch
200 or even go above that now obviously
going above 200 200 000 is a huge
milestone
so there'll be a lot of media coverage
and that's what leads to a
what they call a fear of missing out
rally so generally that happens every
few years and i think uh
you know a fomo rally for bitcoin has
been due for a long time now
i mean we we bobby maybe just at the end
we've seen this regulatory crackdown in
china from everything from fintech to
cryptos
does it change in any way how you
operate now
in your business
with ballet
yeah my business is selling hardware
wallets so we are not impacted by this
and also you know for this being my
second startup from the outset i knew to
position our business to not rely on the
china market so after the earlier
crackdown our sales in china have indeed
come down but for me it's not a big
issue because we've always relied on the
international global market for
cryptocurrency
so for for wallet makers and other
businesses that don't concentrate their
activity in china this crackdown doesn't
make a difference however for those
companies that are focused on the china
market i think this is tougher for them
following the state council's
declaration
provincial governments began taking
proactive measures to stop crypto mining
the regulators justified the new action
mainly on the grounds that bitcoin is
very energy intensive and poses a threat
to the country's environmental goals the
fact that the crypto industry is
intensively searching for a more
environmentally friendly version of
bitcoin has already been presented with
the china green token project
chia has been dubbed the green altcoin
how exactly is it greener than bitcoin
well first of all instead of relying on
electricity and custom hardware to prove
that you're correctly validating the
chain we instead rely on unused hard
drive space and what you do is you fill
your space with what is the equivalent
of a bingo card and you just store it on
your drive until you happen to win that
challenge and get the chance to validate
a transaction
and hard drives use significantly less
power if all the hard drives that we're
going to ship this year a whole
zettabyte worth
we're compared to just say ethereum
that's like one-tenth the total energy
usage per year
so if chia really takes off though then
doesn't that create a need for more
storage and need for more hard drives
which ultimately creates more waste and
then that's another problem for the
environment well look there's two things
that are important here thing one is you
know better than what you know a bicycle
is much more efficient than a tesla but
that doesn't mean that we don't want
tesla's to compete with suvs um we are a
much greener alternative with more
security in fact than both bitcoin and
ethereum we have about 500 000 nodes
compared to bitcoin's 40 000 nodes but
actually what we're doing is we're
putting used hard drives back in service
when facebook or box gets to the four
year end of life of those drives they
get sold to recyclers and what's been
happening is for our farmers has been
buying those and instead of them going
to a landfill or farming them
so you just announced plans to go public
and as i understand it the plan is to
become an exchange a broader payment
system can you talk to us about what the
overall ambitions are
yeah we believe that blockchain should
have gotten product market fit in 2017
but there were regulatory problems and
the functionality that was available on
most chains really wasn't yet ready for
enterprise or government adoption our
new on-chain programming environment
chilis is very much designed to support
things like central bank digital
currencies uh distributed exchanges so
things like carbon credit markets later
equities
and one of the things we did very
differently is we've taken the company
form to you know drive the adoption of a
blockchain
we expect to build kind of a red hat
business where we're supporting the
adoption of blockchain infrastructure
for the people who need it
and our strategy to go public is very
much a product strategy for for a lot of
companies going public is an exit for us
it actually uh helps clarify the
regulations it kind of makes it more
clear that this is our equity versus
these are our coins which are a
commodity
and it also allows our users to for
example use our equity to
shield themselves from some of the coin
volatility that these coins often have
now there's been some backlash against
chia for being a for-profit company
backlash around the timing of the ipo
chia's founder bram cohen also the
inventor of bit
torrent recently tweeted i'd like to
emphasize we aren't selling any tokens
have raised money under normal
investment terms and chia is not a
security some community members are
being obnoxiously entitled and should
knock it off what's your response to the
push we are trying we are trying to
build a real community of civility and
actual interest in the technology you
know this is a 30 plus year opportunity
and we're no rush to try to be there
first what we want to do is to actually
go and solve the real problems people
have things like being able to transfer
money between banks into different
countries
things like sending money home to
guatemala you know these things should
be easier to do than cash they should be
cheaper than they currently are and
those are the things we're really
focused on you know there certainly is a
bit of a gold rush effect where people
want to get in and get in early for chia
farming and chia farming is very
approachable it's not super easy not yet
and we'll make it easier but i think
there's some frustration and especially
around uh detail which is pooling
allowing people to kind of share their
rewards
but we're going to have that for people
very shortly
you say it's greater than bitcoin is it
greener than ethereum two
so the thing about ethereum two is that
well it's gonna be available in three
months for the last two years uh we
don't think proof of stake is actually
secure when you start talking about
intergovernment kind of uh competitions
proof of stake has all sorts of problems
that really nakamoto consensus which is
what bitcoin is and which we are evolved
from really fixed um you know there are
problems like every proof-of-stake chain
is available for 50.1 percent of the
value of the chain and if you were to
buy it you own it for the future uh
where like bitcoin or chia can recover
from a 51 attack and keep going
now obviously there's been a lot of
volatility in the crypto market in
general but there's the chia coin itself
has been super volatile
since launch what do you make of that
well i think it was trying to find a
price uh and you know i think it has now
found a price if you kind of look out
over the last two weeks it's been in uh
yeah i'll call it 600 to 1100 range
in crypto that's a narrow range for
other folks that's not as usual a range
that they're used to
so
i i do want to ask you one last question
about elon musk you mentioned tesla
earlier and obviously elon musk has had
a lot of influence on price fluctuations
over the last several weeks do you think
that's a good thing or that is that
unhealthy
well you know i think at least elon was
looking at the right issues which are
that cryptocurrency is uh the way of the
future but that there are real concerns
around the carbon footprint that
ethereum and bitcoin have today um but
you know i will say it this way
celebrities will be celebrities you know
we're very much more focused on actually
getting this blockchain adopted by real
users
so you think he's just a celebrity
well certainly not in the rocket
business or in the car business or the
solar business but in the blockchain
space uh you know uh i i like to joke uh
he once tweeted that uh he'd wanted
blockchains to be 10 times faster and 10
times cheaper and i'm hoping that my
plaid model s is going to be 10 times
cheaper too
[Music]
but the answer to the question of
environmental sustainability is not the
only key to success
china keeps providing environmental
reasons to introduce more regulations
and above all which countries are
leading in this respect
is finding an answer to the
environmental sustainability part of the
piece really crucial here
good morning thanks for having me on the
show it's great to be here honey and you
know i think this is a really important
question for for all industries uh and
and you know crypto is no uh is not
excluded from that set uh you know we
don't stand alone so you know i think
the the really interesting thing about
uh crypto is that it's a it's an almost
kind of um marginal efficiency
uh maximalist so it is seeking the
lowest sources of power and we know that
renewables are so you know the latest
stats that i've seen with that um crypto
miners uh in particular bitcoin mining
which has the most impost um is is in
the 50 to 60 range for use of renewables
which is well above you know industry
averages that being said it's it is a
long way to go there and and i think it
is a key part of the story for crypto
because you know this latest uh ban from
china which you mentioned
one of several that we've seen um
it's you know that's driven i think from
from but maybe they're tied up but i
think you know the the china van has is
it's part of a bigger story uh for china
in general and it's something that we're
you know obviously not happy to see but
but from the energy point of view um
what that has meant and the previous
bands in china for mining you know
earlier this year has been that mining
has moved uh offshore it it's now you
know accounts for only 45 of mining is
in china and that will likely uh likely
reduce over time and and the more that
mining moves offshore out of china and
the more that it moves into places where
there's faster and faster uptake of
renewables uh and uh that the us's is
one of those locales uh we'll see the
that energy mix change for for crypto
and the last thing i'll say on this is
that um
the the
different blockchains that exist out
there you know bitcoin is one of them um
you might have heard of ethereum i'm
sure um these are they're looking at
alternative ways to secure the network
and and so proof of stake which is a
it's a different method for for uh
securing these transactions and securing
the distributed ledger
a lot of new technologies new coins
and existing coins are transitioning to
this type of methodology and i think
that will have an impact
yeah i was going to ask you about proof
of stake because even with the proof of
stake blockchains they're not created
equally right in theory actually ranks
pretty poorly out of some of the others
is it really kind of the environmental
savior here
it's part of the story i think the main
uh the
the the savior here is is uh
generation needs to change to renewables
and and uh crypto will move uh even
faster because we know that uh you know
renewable energy is the cheapest source
of energy now uh and and every new
project in fact there are some
australian projects that are really
quite interesting modular mining
projects they're part of the they can
actually empower the energy transition i
think you know crypto being something
that uh can be located crypto miners
that is can be um located on site uh
we're seeing projects that are you know
uh setting up on site uh dealing with
excess excess supply you know we've got
excess supply issues in australia when
it comes to peak uh peak solar in the
middle of the day and you can um
leverage some modular uh consumption
here so so bitcoin's not not just the
enemy it's part of it it's part of a
transition and it's quite an interesting
tool in that but the real issue is
generation and we're seeing that change
and i think crypto will follow
we have seen this new experiment of
cross-border uh digital currency by the
bank of international settlements not to
mention the monetary authorities of
china and hong kong what will digital
currencies do to other crypto assets
it's a really interesting question
because you know we've we've seen the
announcement recently that you know
platforms like twitter uh have have
added crypto to their to their to their
network um you can t tip people on on
the platform using using bitcoin uh and
there was some really interesting videos
showing showing people uh tipping uh
cross border so all of a sudden you know
twitter is now a a cross-border uh
payments platform as well as a social
media network and and that's the power
of of blockchain and crypto it it's
native to the internet and it can plug
into any app so i think that the rise of
central bank digital currencies is also
that's something interesting but
what what has been proven over the last
12 to 24 months um by the rise of uh
stable coins and the use of crypto and
cross-border flows is that it's it's a
superior form of money it it works
better in that in that context and so
you're going to see
central banks take you make use of that
technology you know
it's a new internet it's a new rail so
so these things will coexist
unfortunately in a place like china
they're trying to enforce uh one one
type of currency we've see we've seen
the attitudes to tech and general uh and
that's an unfortunate thing for i think
for uh emerging businesses and the
chinese community there who are so
quick to embrace new technology right so
you know
crypto and and central bank digital
currencies will coexist in the future
when it comes to embracing new
technologies uh developing their digital
currencies
and perhaps the development of
regulations as well which countries are
leading
uh i mean
we're a kraken is a really proud u.s
dollar style business and we have a a
footprint here in australia we've got a
local footprint here and in many other
countries and and different countries
have different flavors and the
regulatory framework is something that's
um that shifts and changes and and so
and that and that has a big part to play
in terms of adoption right now if you're
gonna if you're gonna tell me who the
most um uh advanced uh crypto bit uh
countries are you you can't not mention
um countries that have adopted it as
legal tender like el salvador but you
know there's there's so much innovation
coming out of of europe coming out of
switzerland where there's a lot of uh
domiciled foundations for some of the
the most interesting technologies the us
has a huge amount of uh vibrant and
exciting projects it's a it's a global
technology and and and where the people
are where the people are is what matters
and interestingly there's some really
fascinating projects coming out of
australia as well
for most of 2020 the chinese government
was tightening its grip on
cryptocurrency exchange activities
within its border as part of an ongoing
campaign to fight money laundering and
fraud in august the pboc announced its
intention to block over 100 foreign
websites offering crypto exchanges
the problem facing china's crypto
industry in 2021 began in may when the
state council doubled down on previous
crypto policies by calling for
restrictions on crypto mining and
trading
previously provincial authorities in the
inner mongolia xinjiang and citron
provinces all of which were major
bitcoin mining hubs have begun to
introduce measures restricting the
operation of bitcoin miners
similar to the prosecution of crypto
exchange in 2017 bitcoin miners were
forced to either permanently stop
operating or relocate to other crypto
friendly countries since around 50
of the world's bitcoin mining output was
generated in china before the ban the
global bitcoin economy filled the impact
of china's bitcoin mining ban as
expected
just give us your take about beijing
walking away from crypto assets
all right good morning and thank you
very much for having me well
even if you take it aside from the whole
crypto issue i think as a soft power
move this may perhaps be a misstep from
china
um
as countries uh you know that are trying
to be within its sphere of influence if
you look at the likes of el salvador if
you look at laos if you look at
afghanistan those are all countries that
are moving towards the use of
cryptocurrency just as china is pulling
back now where that's concerning for the
chinese is that they've put so much
effort into their soft powers um you
know their outreach that they've been
conducting globally particularly if you
look at their efforts that they've done
in latin america and as they're putting
back and these countries and regions are
moving in that's going to cause a
problem for them down the line yeah we
have seen even ftx the exchange
decision to move its headquarters from
hong kong to the bahamas those moves to
latam as you mentioned
what does this mean
practically speaking for all of these
companies that have relations with china
chinese users as well
well that's true if you look at um both
horby and okx okay exchange to
well-known behemoths from china that
trading crypto we saw the impact on
their token in trading over the weekend
both experience considerable drops in
value and certainly for companies that
have that exposure to china with chinese
clients will be scrambling over the
weekend and onwards to try and withdraw
their positions it is of deep concern
for anyone with that level of exposure
but i think what's important is to frame
it within the crypto industry itself the
industry has proven its robustness time
and again this is the second time this
year that china has effectively tried to
ban crypto and the fourth time since
2013.
yes absolutely the industry saw a drop
off in bitcoin price in june when the
last uh ban came through but we can see
what happened in the months subsequent
and if you look at trading over the
course of the weekend in bitcoin yes
there was an impact as you would expect
but we're also reading off the back of
what's happening with evergrand and the
wider implications there
what instead this tells us is further
proof of the robustness when it comes to
cryptocurrency particularly as it takes
its place and the global stage so i
think that um for us we're looking at
what happens in china with great
interest but equally and with certain
measure we're looking at what's
happening out of the u.s and where
they're taking their regulation
particularly considering how you know
the pivot that we've seen over the
course of this year westwood towards
bitcoin mining and regulation overall so
yes absolutely if i was a company that
had exposure to china and i was related
to to cryptocurrency i would be
concerned however the rest of us wider
industry we're rolling with the punches
and caroline you take a look at the
long-term uh trend direction when it
comes to bitcoin right we're still
pretty far off the all-time high of
above 60 000. uh do you see that market
recovery and how much of it has really
priced in
the news out of china given yes it is
more severe but we have been hearing
variations of this sentiment since about
2019.
yeah absolutely i think you know i think
that the price tip that we saw is
probably indicative i mean there was it
was less than ten percent of things i
think it's between five to seven percent
drop off over the weekend and the price
but it counted that then with the other
news that came out with regards to
twitter we'd have said it will now allow
its users to send and receive bitcoin so
while you've got the negative coming out
of china you also on the other hand have
got 330 million twitter users you will
now be able to use bitcoin um as part of
their social media transactions so it's
certainly you know kind of climbing in
its ascendancy do i think we're going to
see the 60 000 price point again
the trend would suggest that that's the
direction that we're heading in do i
think over the longer term that we're
going to see the use case for bitcoin
absolutely but i think anyone would be
um rather foolhardy to say that this is
it this is the one and only i think that
time has shown us in history and human
civilization has shown us that we like
to change what we use as a method of
value exchange and certainly i would
imagine that for bitcoin there's going
to be many pretenders to its crown
so when it comes to australia of course
there's been lots of criticisms from
within the crypto industry that
regulation or i guess a nurturing
ecosystem has fallen behind compared to
other places like singapore or even
parts of the middle east right do you
expect is there to be a more
fruitful conversation about
cryptocurrency or is there a chance that
we'll see some of these jurisdictions
taking china's lead
well this is the real opportunity for
australia and this is certainly a
message that the industry has been
trying to deliver to both government and
regulators um and we wait with interest
to see the report that's due to come out
from the senate um
this month actually sorry in october
next month
this is the real opportunity with china
retreating from the field there is a
chance now for countries such as
australia to really step forward we've
also got the opportunity when it comes
to kind of the green um mining of
bitcoin with all the green energy
solutions that are available here if you
look at the opportunity for example that
iran has taken it now contributes 4.5 of
bitcoin mining globally according to
figures relief and elliptic that shows
the opportunity that is there that other
nations are stepping forward but we then
have to ask ourselves do we want this uh
to come out of countries such as iran el
salvador etc or do we feel as though
there's an opportunity for australia to
step forward particularly when you look
at other um local countries to us here
in asia pacific if you look at where
singapore has been going um in
particular which has been very much a
beacon for the industry i think there's
an opportunity for greater partnership
collaboration and supposed to find the
australian way forward with this um and
certainly you know that's something that
industry is very strongly pushing
forward
china also trying to hammer down on some
of the crypto mining how do prices
respond
uh it has been an incredibly volatile
week for for bitcoin and this latest
news from china just really hammered it
again
it's the second time this week that news
out of china has really impacted the
cryptocurrency um first with it saying
that it
wouldn't allow financial institutions to
use it and we're going to crack down on
it more and now with this latest news
about cracking down on mining and it's
it's really thrown the cryptocurrency
for another loop
yeah i mean this is testing a lot of
folks out there uh and good thing crypto
doesn't trade on weekends right
question
it's a trick question
i wish that would
go ahead
oh i just i i wish that uh that
cryptocurrency um took a break on the
weekends but yeah it continues to trade
and so this weekend we might even see
more volatile moves just given that
usually on weekends there is lighter
volumes and so sometimes we see even
more volatility then claire we love
though that it trades on weekends that
means that you as a reporter have a job
on saturday and sunday which we know
that you love talk to us though about
it just in terms of how we think about
this going forward when you get comments
from china any little pause really makes
the
currency or the crypto space so volatile
what does this mean really going forward
well it seems like the only thing that's
certain is that you know volatility
probably will continue for bitcoin um
from what i've heard talking with
investors is that around these movements
with bitcoin it it does impact the
broader market in a way obviously not
the main factor
but i think it's hard for
investors trading stocks and bonds to
see
how wild things are with bitcoin and not
be impacted somehow and so we have seen
a bit of a
risk off mood sometimes when bitcoin is
getting hammered
and that could continue i am curious
well though i mean we have seen the
correlations particularly this week and
last week uh really sort of move in
lockstep with regards to crypto and then
some of the other risk assets like
equities here and there are a lot of
people that used to talk about how
crypto could sort of be a hedge to some
of the normal equity market volatility
here if this core if this correlation
sort of persists here is that going to
create maybe a little bit further of a
shakeout is anyone talking about that
yet
a little bit i think the the main thing
people are focused on is inflation and
are very much looking at signs of that
and you know there's a question of how
does bitcoin react when we see further
inflation
obviously we know that tech doesn't like
measures of inflation rising
but it's i think the
idea of bitcoin as a hedge is still sort
of evolving and people are trying to
figure out
what its price movement is correlated
with most often
[Music]
as if banning bitcoin mining wasn't
enough chinese regulators decided to ban
crypto trading completely in september
unlike previous bans on crypto
transactions the country's central bank
in cooperation with nine other
government agencies including the police
and the supreme court eliminated all
doubts about the country's attitude to
cryptocurrencies leaving absolutely
nothing for misinterpretation
the regulators have classified all
crypto transactions both from crypto to
crypto and vice versa trading and
investments as illegal regardless of
whether they were conducted through
local or foreign platforms
this includes all bitcoin ethereum and
tethered transactions
chinese nationals working in marketing
or technical support for foreign
exchange may now face prosecution
the ndrc has outlined plans to exit
crypto mining completely by seizing
investment in the sector increasing
electricity costs and denying new
companies access to the industry
as katie mentioned we've seen this story
play out somewhat before not too big of
a surprise still is this a is a pretty
big setback for the crypto community
you're right and thank you so much for
having me on this is not the first time
that chinese regulators have made such a
statement previous attempts to outlaw
crypto really went nowhere i do think
that it's notable because it comes not
long after the miners fled inner
mongolia so there's a bit more dynamics
at play i think in regards to price
action and some of the the deeply rooted
fundamentals regarding the mining
and so stefan i'm curious if you look at
the price action today you saw bitcoin
drop close to nine percent but you saw
other coins really drop a lot more i
mean if i look at ether i think it got
close to around 11 percent or so i'm
curious why bitcoin was the relative
outperformer this morning is it somewhat
of a haven at this point
i think it's very reasonable to think
that uh that bitcoin is a haven i also
think that uh you know there's much more
of a fundamental thesis around bitcoin
it's more mature asset so to see it find
kind of fundamental support you know it
is more is more understandable people do
have financial metrics sorry fundamental
metrics they apply to bitcoin so they
have their levels much more so than i
think they do in some of these altcoins
that are a lot newer you know they're
based on you know highly speculative use
cases et cetera et cetera so i i think
it makes sense in these sell-offs that
uh you know btc which is uh
which i think you could make a lot more
fundamental arguments for finds support
sooner and so leah just again focusing
on the price action so even though this
wasn't new news you did see bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies react we are
heading into the weekend and we know
that the crypto markets are wide open
during the weekends and that it tends to
be a volatile time what are you
expecting what could we be waking up to
on on monday morning
yeah absolutely well assets appear to
have found a floor but as you mentioned
weekends tend to be volatile and how
they react is definitely anyone's guess
but you know to your point you know
bitcoin did drop about ten percent
before finding resistance at about forty
thousand recovering to about forty one
thousand as mentioned it sold off about
10 as well remains well below 3 000 and
those other alt coins are down even more
however cardano did seem to surge higher
on the news which is quite interesting
so i i think that it's it's maybe
anybody's guess but we'll have a fun
weekend for sure savannah i'm wondering
about what this means for the
opportunity that other countries have if
china's cracking down
could this be a good thing for other
countries
yeah i mean i think that there was
i think one of the confusions around the
chinese crypto crackdown is that a lot
of
you know about a year ago there were a
wave of crypto proponents that suggested
due to china's move into the digital
yuan and the fact that they moved that
ahead very quickly that they were pro
crypto i mean
i really don't believe that that's ever
been the case i mean as as we know
china's been trying to crack on crypto
since 2013 they're a country with strict
foreign exchange controls and for an
asset class like cryptocurrency which is
promising more financial freedom you
know they've always disliked it so you
know i don't think that this i really
don't think this is an incremental shift
in terms of the opportunity set because
china has never wanted to be in crypto
but perhaps it'll change the perception
in the u.s as you mentioned earlier that
hey you know this is something we can
get ahead of china in and maybe that
will be something that uh that that
pushes regulators to have
more favorable regulation towards the
crypto companies um but yeah i don't
think that i really think that this is a
rehash of prior of prior
statements regulations you know as leah
suggested so i i'm i'm not saying this
is changing the opportunity set and in
fact you know i think the bigger news of
the day was probably positive which was
uh which was the twitter launch well
yeah yeah go ahead katie no tim you go
ahead why why staphon talk a little bit
about that this idea that you can
actually tip using bitcoin and through
through your twitter account
yeah well i mean you know i think if you
if you came yesterday we should know
yeah and uh exactly within the last kind
of 24 hours it's been enabled i mean
you're talking about if you're we're
thinking about
fundamental incremental increases in
bitcoin usage right so we're saying that
you know people in china who have been
finding ways to use bitcoin haven't been
allowed so call that flat no change
there and now we've got this uh you know
this very well-known high-profile firm
that's you that's applying bitcoin for a
real use case i mean it's it's
definitely incremental to its utility
value as somewhat of and in addition to
that you know there's the there's so
many different arguments for bitcoin at
the store the store value payment
mechanism this is kind of a you know a
new concept and uh yeah i think it's
very interesting and and you know as
leah mentioned as larry mentioned we're
we seem to be finding some support here
and perhaps you know those those
positive thoughts will prevail
and leah speaking of use cases speaking
of other countries i want to quickly get
your thoughts on el salvador because
bitcoin is actually legal tender in el
salvador and i'm curious if you have
countries such as china really trying to
ban crypto entirely it's another
country's legal tender how is that going
to work
yeah very nuanced indeed i will just
note stefan i agree with you i think
it's very exciting indeed that uh that
twitter integrated not only just bitcoin
tipping but also lightning um to your
point katie this is interesting i think
because this saber rattling from china
comes at a time when the digital one is
starting to gain traction in regards to
what you're saying about el salvador and
why that matters
again the problem with declaring bitcoin
illegal is that it's el salvador's
national currency and people who conduct
business between the two countries may
be doing so in bitcoin um so i think
that following el salvador's move to
make bitcoin its national currency a
number of other nations including costa
rica have been making similar moves and
statements
a number of other countries including
ukraine and cuba have either passed
crypto regulations or in the case of
panama and the us are signaling that
those rules are soon to arrive so you
know i think what it comes down to is
markets have been made and there are
profits to be had i think it's very hard
to outlaw cryptocurrencies on a global
scale
despite china's severe crackdown the
country has remained an important global
crypto market
chinese crypto wallets have received
coins worth around 150 million dollars
so far
this means china remains second in the
ranking following the us according to a
report by analytics provider china
lalysis
[Music]
henry arslanian crypto leader at pwc
said most crypto exchanges overseas
still do not accept customers from the
us now exactly the same exchanges may
have to ban customers based in china as
well for most global crypto exchanges
accepting customers from china has
always been a great market now that
ambiguity has been eliminated
[Music]
but even if large exchanges are
forbidden to china-based traders the
decentralized structure of the exchanges
makes it very difficult to stop people
from holding anything in any country
arselanian said the pboc is also
preparing to launch an official digital
renminbi making it a pioneer in this
field
[Music]
the currency is to be launched in a
trial run during the 2022 winter
olympics
jason guthrie head of digital
investments and asset manager with the
mushri in europe said china's attempt to
ban cryptocurrencies is just a
continuation of a trend but they are
intensifying the rhetoric ahead of the
launch of the digital renminbi
[Music]
edith young a partner at ray's capital
talks to bloomberg technologies emily
chang about future strategies for
investing in china as a country faces
turbulence and how the recent crackdown
can be a good thing for the crypto
ecosystem in the long term perspective
i'm curious for you as an investor how
this china checked crackdown is
impacting your strategy and where you're
putting your money
well personally i take a very long term
view on on china and obviously you're
hearing all these crackdowns about china
on a daily basis almost but i do want
all investors to keep in mind that china
is the second still like the second
largest biggest market in the world over
1.4 billion people
15 trillion gdp
um especially what i focus on in the
venture space just look at sequoia china
they did 96 deals in the last last 90
days so things definitely are not
slowing down per se
but having said that of course everyone
in china needs to play by the rules
doesn't really matter that you alibaba
mate juan or dd or even the bboc or the
cic
no one can really outsmart our play
chinese government but having said that
particular on spec and exit um really
great to learn what's the latest going
on with spec
actually one of my portfolio company
called dated cook
mainly operates sort of the tastemade of
china um they are actually going um on a
spec on nasdaq uh very soon merch with
ace global and that is still happening
so in some sense
go ahead would you say would you say
have you changed your strategy at all
given the china crackdown are you
putting in just as much money
as you would have or are you changing
where that money goes
um i
really want to go back to china because
of covert i've been here for two years
now and not able to go back really makes
it really really tough for me to invest
in china um mostly from a race capital
strategy is to focus on early stage
putting early and support on
infrastructure software
um right now the world is so big and
everybody really worked distributed and
remotely so it doesn't really matter in
china or not but i have to say that most
of the reinvestment lately has been
mostly in silicon valley we invested in
data breaks we invested in ftx those are
all super global and go to market in
both world
well it's interesting that you mentioned
ftx because they recently moved their
headquarters from hong kong to the
bahamas in part because of this
crackdown and so i guess i'm curious
over the long term how do you see this
playing out in china i mean do you see
the chinese government easing up on some
of these restrictions or
if this is you know the long term
strategy how do you think that impacts
the tech ecosystem there long term
i think technical systems need to play
by the rules it doesn't really matter
how big you are you have to comply by
chinese law and especially recently with
this year the data privacy protection
law is key key thing i think as an
investor you need to be aware of that i
don't think we should drift our
investment strategy just because what's
happening in china but it's something
that we have to keep in mind there is
certainly still tons of upside because
the market is so big but then at the
same time there could be some ceiling
because what's going on um i do think
that there's certain industries
particularly more
more
interesting for venture particularly on
the semiconductor and healthcare
because it's not really as close to data
consumer data which is very very
sensitive in china so therefore um being
an investor you should we just need to
be super nimble and pay attention to
what's going on in china
and what about crypto in particular i
mean
you know trading mining in china has
become illegal so is crypto a more
extreme
example how do you see the crackdown
there in impacting the broader landscape
and
investing
so china always have a love-hate
relationship with crypto
um and in 2008 um that's when i was
still going back to the china food law
force
china was the number one in terms of
crypto mining and was the number one in
terms of crypto trading
and since 2018 uh 2017 they've been ico
2018 they then fiat to crypto um trading
which then
then you started to see binance crypto
to crypto trading in 2019 until today um
crypto mining is all banned so in that
sense the biggest difference i do wanted
to point out is that
when the first crackdown happened it
really impacted bitcoin prices to about
3 000.
today according to um you know coin
gecko is about 55 000 dollars uh
equivalent for bitcoin so i think the
the crackdown in china on crypto in some
sense is rebalancing the crypto
ecosystem and longer term is actually a
good thing
for the blockchain ecosystem because now
china influence is actually getting less
and less
[Music]
in recent years it has become clear how
resolutely china is acting against
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
while the policy of the people's
republic with regard to btc was
characterized by waiting and watching in
the first few years the negative
attitude seems to be manifesting itself
more and more due to the increasing
popularity of crypto
numerous sources point out that this
could have something to do with fighting
possible capital inflow in addition it
has been known for a long time that
china is working on its own digital
currency which is centrally in the hands
of the authorities and is supposed to
function in principle like conventional
fiat money only electronically
as a news agency dpa reports the digital
urine is far advanced in its development
and is already being used in some areas
it is therefore not surprising that the
chinese government is doing everything
it can to ban crypto competition
even during the pandemic of coronavirus
the chinese government continue its
opposition to bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies and intensified its
crackdown on illegal crypto
it has always claimed the fight against
fraud and money laundering as the reason
for its intense action
more and more foreign websites have been
blocked by crypto exchanges to prevent
domestic investors from trading
cryptocurrencies and thus protect them
from the risks of unregulated trading in
cyber currencies
even though cryptocurrencies always
react to every event described here with
strong price fluctuations bitcoin's
rising trend seems to be unbroken we
will have to wait and see whether it
continues to do so
[Music]
you